J'aime servir les gens dans
L'Allemagne et j'aimerais ça
continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
J'ai grandi ici de 3 57
jusqu'au lycée et que ce soit de ce que je
discours
mais je veux encore te rappeler
avec tout le paternalisme gouvernemental et
la servitude que nous avions mais j'en ai beaucoup
beaucoup de bons souvenirs à moi
enfance et jeunesse ici à l'équipe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes fonctions
justice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons progressivement jusqu'à la fin de 2022
complètement sur l'énergie nucléaire
renoncer à
et ce chemin en est un pour l'allemagne
grand défi mais il veut dire
surtout, d'énormes opportunités
pour les générations futures
[Musique]
et bien sûr c'est du plus grand
importance
que les programmes que nous utilisons
La Grèce a également accepté
à continuer ainsi
en Grèce le
difficile est difficile mais est
néanmoins continué
[Musique]
à l'âge de 17 ans, il l'a fait
moteur de croissance et ancre de stabilité
L'Europe 
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je ne me sens pas toujours personnellement
que je suis chancelier donc si je
puis cuisine plus tôt en tant que chancelier
[Musique]
la russie et le motif dans lequel nous sommes à
approcher ces choses doit être
car nous avons tant fait nous
laisse faire
[Musique]
ce ne sera pas facile maintenant
les semaines arrivent mais nous sommes cdu/csu
les parties leur responsabilité pour le pays
pour notre programme consacrer son bénéfice
augmenter et leur souhaiter du succès
et
[Musique]
2 ce quatrième mandat sera mon dernier
en tant que chancelier de la république fédérale
L'Allemagne aux élections fédérales 2021
je ne reviendrai que
candidat à la chancellerie de l'union
[Musique]
il est particulièrement important d'être confiant
seraient encore plus démocrates, c'est beaucoup
bon et il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter
[Musique]
pour quelqu'un comme moi pour voyager et
liberté de mouvement difficilement gagnée
ces restrictions sont justes
seulement en cas de nécessité absolue
tout à fait mérité ils devraient être dans un
démocratie jamais à la légère et seulement
mais ils seront temporairement fermés
sont en ce moment
essentiel pour sauver des vies
[Musique]
qu'ils apportent tout
Les prochains bien pensés de l'Allemagne
années
[Musique]